alors je viens de loin de la styrie
malgré que je ça fait sept ans que je
suis à paris
mais mon âme reste dans mon pays pour
vous raconter l'histoire d'une ville
merveilleuse qui a vécu un passé
merveilleux c'est pas venir qui se
trouvent presque au milieu de la syrie
au milieu de la steppe le point de
départ c'est de troisième millénaire
ça veut dire à peu près 3000 ans avant
jésus-christ où les palmes iranienne de
la steppe vont passer de situations
impossibles à une situation possible
ils vont créer une ville au milieu de la
steppe dont les sables ils vont créer et
construire une cité avec sérieux avec
ses monuments et cette idée va continuer
à vivre à peu près deux millénaires
jusqu'à l'arrivée des romains qui vont
la diffuser par des idées qui vient de
l'occident qui vient de l'italie et
qu'ils vont recréer par les palmes
iranienne une ville merveilleuse avec
ses monuments religieux
ces monuments funéraires ses monuments
général de quartiers d'habitation et de
tout ce qui constitue ville en plus de
ça palmyre était là pour gérer les
routes de communication qui relie
pratiquement la méditerranée orientale
avec la mésopotamie et par là avec le
monde iranienne jusqu'à la vallée de
l'indus et jusqu'à l'asie centrale
c'est une ville qui a contribué à créer
par ses palmes iranienne un art local
une langue locale et surtout une
architecture locale
malgré qu'il a été un petit peu
influencé par les romains mais c'est ce
qu'on appelle à partir de palmyre dorion
et l'elysée ça veut dire que lorient qui
a appris ce qui est important dans
l'architecturé de la grèce mais qui l'a
transformé suivant le goût local
cette ville qui va passer d'un projet
d'une situation assez merveilleux va
connaître à partir de 2 10e siècle et
11e siècle après jésus-christ une phase
d'abandon alors tout ce que n'est
palmyre aignan ont construit va devenir
propriété progressivement des ruines et
il faut attendre le xviiie siècle pour
que les premiers occidentaux passent
pour enregistrer et pour commencer à
documenter
cet héritage et il y à la période du
xxème siècle où on voit la
reconstruction de certains monuments et
surtout la consolidation de certaines
par chance j'étais les derniers l'edf
parmi les derniers des équipes syriens
qui ont travaillé là bas c'était en 2011
au moment du déclenchement de la guerre
civile en syrie j'ai passé un mois
merveilleux parmi les ruines
j'étais sonne pratiquement avec mon
équipe et on a profité bien pour étudier
l'histoire de la ville et surtout
l'histoire du noyau dur le plus
important de la ville au centre de la
ville ce qu'on appelle le sanctuaire de
bell on a essayé de voir des différentes
phases d'occupation depuis ce troisième
millénaire jusqu'à la phase deux
bisontines parce que c'est à partir de
cette page peut on a une petite église
dans ce monde malheureusement et là je
peux vous dire tout de suite que je ne
peux pas vous donner des photos
parce que cette situation me dérange
énormément
je ne peux pas voir cette ville après
après mon passage qui était le dernier
je ne peux pas voir je préfère garder
les souvenirs
de d'un élève disons d'une situation
extraordinaire dans moi c'est pour cela
je porte de parler et je laisse à vous
d'imaginer de drames que j'ai vécu au
moment de cette guerre civile alors les
premières trois années les choses ont
passé calmement mais c'est à partir du
mois de mai où une situation va devenir
un petit peu dramatique
qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est que les
jets à nice devant s'approcher de la
ville et d'un seul coup
l'armée du régime va se retirer et la
main va des géantistes va dominer la
plus elle va pas tarder
au bout de deux mois et vous avez les
dames derrière
au bout de deux mois la destruction la
machine de destruction va commencer et
on retrouve en recevrez tous les 2 jours
3 jours
une mauvaise nouvelle la destruction de
détente la destruction d'hôtels tempe ou
bien une série des tombeaux ou bien des
bâtiments qui se trouvent au centre de
la ville alors dg à dix veulent anéantir
complètement les ruines alors tout le
monde va dire que tu ça c'est un message
que ces jihadistes ils veulent pas les
monuments payen au départ on peut être
on peut suivre ses démarches
mais en réalité si on essaie de voir au
fond des choses
les généralistes veulent passer un
message à l'occident que nous on a le
pouvoir d'anéantir les racines de votre
civilisation
parce que c'est à partir de ce monde de
los rios et l'elysée que séné byzance et
après dix ans le moyen âge et le moyen
âge qui va aboutir à la phase actuelle
de la renaissance et de la phase 2 20e
et 21e siècle c'est pour cela c'était au
départ l'idée d'un message orienté vers
anéantir de la phase païenne mais en
réalité non c'est un message un petit
peu plus important c'est un message pour
le monde entier
c'est un message de la capacité de
casser les valeurs de ce monde et les
traces de ses anciennes en fait il se
trouve dans le vent aidant le prochain
quelques mois de présence des dégâts
après c'est le retour du l'armée du
régime soutenu par des forces un petit
peu de tout le la partie iranienne et
russe et le retour était un acte de
propagande de deux triomphes de jusqu'à
un niveau que les autorités ont organisé
à l'intérieur du théâtre qui est un
théâtre du deuxième siècle après
jésus-christ un cancer de musique
classique médiatiser un message de paix
diffusée pour le monde entier où on a
joué malheureusement du bas du prokofiev
et d'autres auteurs et il y avait une
orchestre assez respectueuse
alors c'est un message de propagande et
ça explique ces deuxième partie de la
presse
premier épisode où on a le retour du
forces du régime
mais c'est un retour médiatisé un
message mécanisée pour dire voilà on a
récupéré les valeurs du
du passé des ancêtres de la méditerranée
orientale et même pour l'ensemble de la
méditerranée ce qui s'est passé c'est au
bout de quelques mois légers indices
vont retourner sur le site et la
première chose qu'ils vont faire c'est
détruire ce théâtre vous voyez un geste
de propagande
qu'est ce qu'elle va donner vers la fin
bref je ne peux pas vous entraîner
énormément sur l'histoire de cette ville
mais elle a vécu l'un possible
l'impossible est devenu possible dans
l'idée des djihadistes et dans l'idée de
la propagande du régime
maintenant on est dans la deuxième
épisode
il va commencer en mois de mars 2017 et
on est dans le vague
absolument on sait pas qu'est ce qui va
se passer sur site
il ya des projets de reconstruction on
parle qu'on va renaître l'ensemble des
monuments dynamiter et là je me je
m'arrête pour dire que c'est quelque
chose d'impossible
on ne peut pas revivre l'expérience
qu'on a vécu avant d'en avec les
monuments
c'est vrai on parle des techniques
extraordinaires en parle des techniques
révolutionnaires privant le vivre le
monument on va mettre du béton
mais si vous allez me demander et c'est
par là où je termine mon avis
à moi où je laisse de côté le jugement
scientifique et le jugement de tout ce
qui concerne mes travaux et mes
recherches sur ce site
il faut que je vous raconte une histoire
que j'ai vécu durant cette dernière
campagne
une histoire qui m'a mis devant une
situation d'illumination extraordinaire
quand vous le savez 2011 c'était le
début de la guerre civile en syrie alors
la ville de pamiers il n'y avait pas
tout lisse plus tôt j'y tiens sonne
pratiquement avec mon équipe et mon
équipe nous étions trois énormes alors
dans des soirées on habitait à côté du
sanctuaire de bell qui a été dosé de
première et dynamité on habitait à côté
alors j'ai profité comme c'était la
tradition de la mission syrienne
d'amener une chaîne hi fi
mais cette fois ci j'ai bien profité
tous les jours alors j'ai amené la
chaîne hifi à l'intérieur du temple
ça veut dire le lieu le plus saint du
sanctuaire et j'ai commencé à entendre à
partir de 9h 10h avec la tradition des
pièces de la musique et par hasard cette
fois ci j'ai amené avec moi pas mal de
requiem pas mal des messes et je peux
citer le requiem de verdi de requiem de
mozart le requiem de fauré et la petite
messe solennelle de rossini je ne les
remet avec moi je les ai entendu toutes
les télés soir presque
avec un fond de soleil rompit des
étoiles parce que la sonorité à
l'intérieur de ce monument est
extraordinaire alors j'ai profité
pendant au moins dans cinq fois d'avenir
dans cette nuit de cette sonorité là je
peux vous dire si la personne qui va
reconstruire ce monument va arriver à me
donner la même sonorité
j'accepte une réalise de demain tpr
conditions mais je pensais impossible
parce que la pierre ancienne
c'est la pierre ancienne je veux pas
vous entraîner dans des détails de cette
très ancienne
c'est pour cela je peux vous dire de
palmyre en ce moment ci l'impossible du
possible et les rails par deux bourreaux
les réalistes et le régime et 100 is
honey elle va devenir des ruines enfoncé
à l'intérieur de la terre en attendant
un jour une résurrection
une situation qui va l'amener de
l'impossible possible avec une situation
en or